El Nombre
y nodigי
Cómo empecé sobre este SU
sí
Missouri
Que si
Él
Y siempre tendré solo bien
Escucha de ustedes sobre mí y siempre me responde
Y si aún no, sigo esperando
Lléname con eso de que siempre me amas
Dame cada día de nuevo un regalo
Y guíame con tal misericordia como en este mundo se llama misericordia
Que todos canten que no escuchas plegarias
Y sonriamos, seamos sanos y cantemos
Que el Eterno Bendito siempre me ama
Y siempre tendré solo bien
El Eterno Bendito siempre me ama
Y siempre tendré solo bien, y tendré aún más bien
Y tendré sustento, tendré riqueza
Y los solteros y solteras tendrán pareja
Habrá también curación completa y salud fuerte
Vidas hermosas, felices, año tras año
El Eterno Bendito, siempre me ama y siempre tendré solo bien
Y tendré aún más bien y aún más bien
Y aún más bien
Y siempre tendré solo bien